RENE GARCIA
FRANCESCHINI: My name
is Rene Garcia Franceschini.
I'm a junior in the Department
of Civil and Environmental
Engineering.
And my work concerns
routing of drones
in communications-constrained
environments.
So drones are being used
currently more and more
to inspect
infrastructure, especially
after emergency situations.
Well, there's two
problems with using drones
to inspect infrastructure.
One of them is that a lot
of critical infrastructure,
such as pipelines that's
in rural areas, where
4G LTE or GPS coverage
might be spottier.
And the second problem is
that in emergency situations,
a lot of cell towers are
down, such that 4G LTE
signal is unreliable.
So the problem we're
trying to solve
is, how do we
better route drones
to inspect infrastructure in
these communications-uncertain
environments?
And our approach combines work
in team orienteering algorithms
with creating
learning methods such
that the drones
are simultaneously
inspecting nodes,
while also learning
about the communications
space of the map
to learn what the
communications coverage is
at different points.
And our results show that
there is both an increase
in the total score at
the end of the simulation
and also a decrease in
computational time towards--
at the end of the simulation.
And this work
could ultimately be
used to make infrastructure
monitoring quicker and safer.